[Applaus]
jetzt aber mal eine ganz andere Frage
was ist denn bitte mit unseren lieben
Nachbarn los schlimme Nachrichten von
hinterm Deich Holland wählt rechts das
heißt Niederlande Fresse interessiert
kein
Matjes für mich ist das Holland fertig
ja Rechtspopulist cht Wilders und seine
Partei V the Freiheit was immer das
heißt sind mit 37 sitzen stärkste
Fraktion im neuen niederländischen
Parlament das ist jetzt wirklich der
supergauda der da eingetreten ist vor
allem wenn man bedenkt wie oft der Herr
wild das eigentlich schon weg vom
Fenster war in den letzten Jahren am
Wahlabend konnte er es selber kaum
fassen treat will das der seinen Jubel
im Netz
[Applaus]
teilt h
verdomme die Idioten haben mich wirklich
gewählt wie blöd kann man sein ja so
eigentlich ist das gar nicht lustig die
Niederlande wechseln offiziell auf die
dunkle Seite der Gracht meine Damen und
Herren aber das ja am Ende immer um uns
geht was können wir Deutschen daraus
lernen es gab bei denen sehr viel
Unzufriedenheit mit der bisherigen
Regierung unter anderem wegen
Wohnungsnot bei uns zum Glück
unvorstellbar und chert Wilders gibt
sich in seinen Reden plötzlich gemäßigt
astreiner Trick hier aber noch mal der
original sound frag J ich frage sie
wollen sie in dieser Stadt in diesem
Land mehr oder weniger
Marokkaner die Menge skandiert
begeistert
weniger Reg das kann ich
regeln da kann wir das Regel ja ach ja
auf Holländisch klingt einfach alles
putzig oder sogar lupenreiner Rassismus
übrigens jenseits von neuerdings milder
Wortwahl ist der cht natürlich ganz der
Alte geblieben Niederlande den
Niederländern ruft er er will nach
Syrien abschieben den Koran verbieten
das Übliche halt na klar so vor allem
hat ihm aber geholfen vor allem hat ihm
geholfen dass auch die regierende
konservative VVD Partei Migration zum
Wahlkampf Thema Nummer 1 erklärt hat das
hat will das normalisiert genau wie die
niederländischen Medien z.B Quizshows in
denen der legendäre Marokkaner schräg
ausgiebig süße Katzen Baby streicheln
durfte natürlich nur ist ja logisch
blonde weiße Kätzchen ja und
Kindersendung in denen er mit den
anderen Spitzenkandidaten weiß ich nicht
Türmchen baut oder ein
Abschiebegefängnis ich habe keine Ahnung
ohne Not ohne Not warum gibt man dem
Sendezeit im kindertv ist ja so als ob
bei uns höcke Scholz und MZ bei ein Z
oder drei mitmachen
ne ob ihr wirklich richtig steht seht
ihr wenn Berns Arm hoch geht ne ja wobei
das natürlich die große Frage könnte ein
Bern höcke sich überhaupt so verstellen
sag mal wenn der versucht bei der Jugend
zu punkten wird ja eher creepy ich bin
hier gerade mit Herrn Höe im Thüringer
Landtag und J ist richtig geil ja türing
ist noch anderes ganz geil wir sind der
wilde
Osten hö klingt wie ein zwingerclub
Besitzer aberurü zum chert meine Damen
und Herren der chert will das
der versucht jetzt eine Regierung zu
bilden hat sich aber schon von zwei
potenziellen Koalitionspartnern ein
körbche geholt ja man nimmt ihm das
plötzlich softe getour eben nicht ab und
hat zum Glück sein Programm gelesen in
dem sogar ein Referendum zum EU-Austritt
der Niederlande drin steht tja nicht
umsonst feiert Putins
propagandafernsehen den Wilders Erfolg
cht will das das ordöv des Grauens vor
der Europawahl nächsten Juni dem
Kontinent droht ein historischer
Rechtsruck es ist leider so aber ich
weiß jetzt gar nicht wie es Ihnen geht
irgendwie bin ich bei den Holländern
besonders enttäuscht W die waren noch
immer irgendwie cool weltoffen zugekifft
ne und jetzt das und jetzt das oder
haben wir einfach nicht genau genug
hingeguckt damals bei den alten Frau an
Spots meine Mühle ist ein
Flüchtlingsheim mir bleibt n noch diese
alte Käse du murik was sagst du denn so
zur niederländischen
Asylpolitik Muslime raus da hast du
völlig recht recht deshalb schiebt die
Gert die alle ab und wir Holländer haben
den ganzen Käse wieder nur für uns Frau
frisst alles
alleine wenn
schmeckt
ja will das
so Gert wild das triumphiert in den
Niederlanden genau wie Javier mele in
Argentinien und es zeichnet sich da
leider ein globales Muster ab beide sind
Exzentriker und ja frisurtechnisch sagen
wir mal herausgefordert ne da kann sich
die Demokratie aber sehr bald waschen
föhnen und gehackt legen fürchtet
irgendwer mit Medien irgendwer mit
Medien mit Friedrich Küppersbusch
in Deutschland geht's uns ja noch Gold
dank des Grundgesetzes Artikel 5 Absatz
1 sie kennen das eine Frisur findet
nicht statt ich persönlich stehe Haaren
aus biographischen Gründen so ein
bisschen abwartend gegenüber und ich
sehe mich jetzt bestätigt immer mehr
Polit Clowns und Populisten schicken
sich an nach ihrer Facon selig zu werden
gemeinsam führen sie alle ein Kampf
gegen die da oben und mit die da oben
meinen sie leider nicht ihre Frisuren
das architekturfestival auf Kopf von
Donald Trump beansprucht inzwischen
einen eigenen Sitz im Weltsicherheitsrat
Boris Johnson pflegt seine designermütze
persönlich ja das sagen ja leider immer
noch viel zu viele zu Hause Schatz ich
bürste lieber im Büro die Niederlande
haben bekanntlich ihr Staatsgebiet durch
aufpolderung erheblich vergrößert und
durch die Frisur von R Wilders new kid
on the rasiersitz Argentiniens künftiger
Staatspräsident Javier auf seiner Murmel
wohnt seit Jahren ein ausgestopfter
Pudel der an die frühen 70er erinnert
ist das eine Warnung hatte liebe Gott
die fiesen Friesen praktisch so als
Tumormaker auf die Verdächtigen Ommen
genagelt nein politische analysten
vermuten hinter der Struppi Fraktion
einen antiautoritären gesto gegen das
Establishment ich gehe nicht zum Friseur
und das ist geklaut gamler Hippis das
war mal typisch links und deswegen ist
es ganz klar hier wenn überhaupt noch
was passieren soll hier muss man sich
Genen Unterdrücker stellen und man muss
parteiisch sein und nicht hier einfach
sagen und deswegen ma ich jetzt hier
diesen tischm kaputt ja
damit ja der ist heute übrigens
inarchitekt von Claudia R 50 Jahre
später Argentiniens Wahlsieger
m so sehen Sieger aus M Karriere begann
als Nervensäge in Talkshows die Säge
wurde zu seinem Wahrzeichen und hier
zeigt der gruselown wel blödsinnigen
Ministerien er abschaffen wird auch
Donald Trump hatte erst eine steile
Fernsehkarriere Boris Johnson moderierte
in England sogar eine Comedyshow und
richtig liebe verschwörungsfreunde ja
den Schlenker zum gelernten
Fernsehkomiker wodimir selenski hat es
ztf natürlich rausgeschnitten schade
also jetzt haben wir den Kopfsalat diese
Typen haben gelernt bei uns in den
Medien wie sie uns den Medien den Ball
durch den Hosenträger spielen und wir
quoteng geil und gewissenlos halten
immer gerne voll drauf und blasen den
Schlamm in die Welt und deswegen
appelliere ich heute im Namen der
Demokratie weltlangweilige Politiker mit
Glatze Männer Frauen egal und wenn euer
Kandidat noch nicht langweilig genug ist
drückt ihm 5 € in die Hand und schickt
ihn damit nach Hamburg zu bchet AlGaN
dem leibfriseur von Olaf Scholz seit 39
Jahren betreibt bechjet hier seinen
Friseursalon einen Olaf Scholz
Haarschnitt für
4,99 dieses Angebot gibt es wohl nur in
Hamburg Alton für nur 499 jetzt hingehen
bevor Karlsruhe auch noch seine Frisur
verbietet make harchnitt great again
irgendwer mit Medien
mitichusch so und stehe ich richtig
super also dann
los liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
klickt hierhin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take wir haben es ich
sehe auch echt schnicke aus heute